the protocol I've watched a lot of your
videos on this you've gone into
tremendous depth about the blueprint
which I assume is the blueprint on how
to live in a way that slows down aging
and possibly at some point we'll reverse
it but what is the protocol if you can
measure every organ of the body and let
the organs speak about what it wants to
be in an ideal ideal State reference
gold standard scientific evidence and
then create a protocol and then have
perfect adherence you create a system
where the body can maintain itself in an
optimal State now this is in contrast to
typically we approach things in life
where we think our brain is the primary
tool which solves all problems before us
my brain as most brains do is a cause of
a lot of self-destructive Behavior we
are prone to eat too much food or of the
wrong kind of food or drink or other
substances or spend too much time
consuming content not prioritizing sleep
and so the solution for me was to remove
my mind as a problem-solving tool
Empower my body by measurement through
my entire body and then looking at the
evidence and so letting my body solve
its own problems of how to be in the
ideal state is the protocol need
motivation what's your top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because of my
first business I quit I'm a business
partner I struggled to keep going I was
making 300 bucks a month and felt like a
complete failure and the thing that
saved me that pulled me up was studying
the stories of famous entrepreneurs I
got the motivation from them I also got
the strategies of what to do next so
that I can go off and achieve my dreams
and quite honestly I still need the
stories today myself to continue my
motivation to take it to the next level
so today let's learn from one of the
best Brian Johnson and my take on his
top 10 it was a success enjoy
and so I just simply follow the data and
so we look at all the things you would
imagine like blood stool urine saliva
MRI ultrasound Fitness tests DNA
methylation microbiome everything we can
measure we measure and we take all that
data we look at the evidence and we just
do this again and again and so my
responsibility in this is to ensure
perfect adherence to the protocol and we
can see how these things work in an
iterative basis I heard you say that
sleep and diet are probably the two most
important things is that a true
assessment given all the data you've
looked at now
it's a difficult
to
make too strong of statements about
power laws in the entirety because
most people reasonably look at this and
they see that it's not doable for the
average person yeah that's more protocol
I will say that like I've got the
resources to pull it off I've even got
the discipline but I was like
this is a lot it's a lot it's a lot so
especially the part about needles in the
face that's why I was like oh God
so we'll get to that in a minute but so
okay it's hard to break down the power
law your point is correct if you're
going to get just a few things right
sleep I'd say
stop self-destructive behavior and get
good sleep like you don't even have to
eat vegetables berries and nuts like
that would be an advanced thing just
stop doing things that hurt you because
when you do things that cause
self-destructive Behavior it's so hard
that ruins your sleep which then ruins
your willpower to do be able to do good
things it's just a vicious cycle so
sleep well stop bad behaviors and it
gives you get you in a neutral position
to feel like you can start doing some
positive things in your life and gain
some momentum it's ironically it's a lot
of people we all know this uh if we go
to the gym and work out
we feel good about ourselves and later
in the day we want to reward ourselves
and sometimes we reward ourselves in a
way that offsets what happened in the
beginning of the of the good thing so
really the root of it is trying to get
at this self-destructive Tendencies we
have rule number two is get enough rest
can you maybe elaborate on the sleep
thing why is sleep so important
and why I presumably if like what does
good sleep mean to you
I think sleep is a contender
for being the most powerful
Health intervention in existence
it's a contender I mean it's uh it's
magical what it does if you're well
rested and what your body
can do and I mean for example I know
when when I eat close to my bedtime and
I've done a systematic study
four years uh looking at like 15-minute
increments on time of day on where I eat
my last meal my willpower is directly
correlated to my to the amount of deep
sleep I get
so my ability to not binge eat at night
when
Rascal Brian's out about is based upon
how much deep sleep I got the night
before yeah and so there's some there's
a lot to that yeah and so I just I've
seen it manifest itself and so the I
think
the way I summarize this is in society
we've had this myth of we tell stories
for example of Entrepreneurship
where this person was so amazing they
stayed at the office for three days and
slept under their desk yeah and we say
wow that's amazing there's that's
amazing
and now I think we're headed towards a
state where we'd say that's primitive
and really not a good idea on every
level
and so the new mythology is going to be
the exact opposite rule number three is
understand the brain technology is here
to eat us and it's going to be a
negative consequence my question to you
is like why do you think that is the
case why why do we think the worst about
technology and why has that been
programmed into us when it also could be
the complete opposite and some may argue
that it has been the complete opposite
in the last hundred or a thousand years
reflecting back on as what I've learned
in life I would say that
um
looks like it's a roundabout way to get
to your your question and when I was in
my early 20s I started reading a lot of
Behavioral economics and
and specifically learning
how flawed my mind is I learned that I
had over 188
cognitive biases so distortions of
reality that my brain actively makes on
a daily basis and I'm oblivious to it
I wasn't aware prior to reading this
literature I had this default assumption
that I was re I was rational and
consistent and I could see other
people's flaws that I was the one that
was coherently understanding the world
and when I started poking into this
material and I realized how flawed my
my cognition was
and I even my internal dialogues
it fundamentally changed how I
understand myself and the world and so
every thought that landed into my brain
I didn't treat it as right I treat it as
oh interesting
uh let's see what you've delivered
delivered up and how
how many biases are attached to this
thing and so when you when you pose the
question of you know uh
why would media take a topic like uh
artificial intelligence and create these
narratives and why would people respond
that way and then why are these things
forming to me the the most beneficial
thing to do is to understand it as
what's happening in individual Minds
What's happening in Collective Minds
what systems are producing it and why
it's interesting and so in in short
instead of listening to what they're
saying
to dissect the systems that are creating
those things
to see behind the curtain oftentimes
it's not interesting to hear what
someone has to say it's interesting to
understand why they say it rule number
four is be responsible I'm trying to
imagine a kid growing up somewhat
impoverished did that give you a
scarcity mindset were you thinking like
oh making money is hard
and then what was it about that
experience that was so transformative
that it it shakes everything I was
taught to be a responsible child a
responsible person in society and so for
example when my parents split my mom was
a single mother with five kids
we didn't have money so you mentioned
she made clothes for me to go to school
and uh when I was at school I figured
out that I could buy a dailed
uh croissant for 10 cents uh if at post
lunch and so what I do I made a deal to
lunch lady where I would clean the
tables and pay 10 cents and get this
croissant and then I didn't have to cash
my mom's check that she'd written for 25
for my monthly fee to save for the 25 a
month so I did this for a month or two
my Mom finally found out and I think she
was partly embarrassed like my child is
not eating lunch at school and everyone
thinks there's something wrong with the
family but to me that just made sense
that it was my I that's the way I could
contribute to my family is save my mom
25 a month in my in my lunch fee at
school and I guess I've always felt that
sense of responsibility which my my
parents did a nice job of teaching me
that also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
work you will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is have financial
goals you said earlier you said I wanted
to make a certain amount of money by age
30. what was your number what was your
target
but on the
on the lower end it was seven million
dollars I had built out my spreadsheet
model and assumed a certain rate of
interest and basically said if I make a
certain amount of money this is an
annuity that would be good enough for my
entire life assuming I don't need
Capital to do anything like just if it's
time like I'm writing or something
then if I do something in the world I
have mapped out something like 150 300
million as a
a basis that would get me started on
that path
when you sold when you were 34 right
yes and what did you uh what were you
able to walk away with were you able to
hit your your your the north end of your
target yeah I hit 300 million what is
that you know you're you're up religious
Farm kid who doesn't know much in and
then in a matter of 11 or 12 years
you're able to walk away with you know
north of 300 million dollars what does
that feel like and what do you do with
that money once it hits your account
you don't seem like a victory dance kind
of guy
wait a second
uh but true that's true that's true
that is very true
um
it's sobering because
you know it's bigger than what you
realize
but you don't know in what ways
and so it wasn't the case that I had a
long list of things I wanted to buy that
were just waiting for this cash to come
in I don't think I've spent any money
for a long time
and I think you're now looking back now
even my
most uh
aggressive expectations on how life
would change weren't even close
to how significantly my reality would
change over the years with that event
rule number six is make an impact I
think as a species
I think we're teenagers
I think that
the decisions we make in the next
years 20 30 years are going to have
enduring consequences of the sort that
previous decisions did not we need to
figure out as a species what we do with
ourselves
we need to figure out how to co-evolve
with AI
we need to figure out how
the problems that could that could
threaten our Extinction won't extinct us
we need to figure out how to avoid an
anarchic Society we need to figure out
how to avoid a dystopic society
we need to do all this
in a span of I'd say a couple decades
and
I currently don't think as a society we
have the literacy
to do that
and so what I hope is that
more people will sign up
to become future literate in all its
various forms
and that we collectively acknowledge the
importance of our time
because I think if we don't uh we are
going to be blindsided
and it's going to be painful and
regretful if we lose our chance because
we
can build an existence that's remarkable
beyond anything anyone else could
imagine I'm convinced of it
and I hope that enough people will rally
behind that
in all their different forms and
that we have sufficient momentum to do
it
so I hope I can be a part of that group
rule number seven is learn about AI you
have made
a deity of data
and I think inside of all of us there is
a god-shaped hole
it has not played out as religion in my
life not since I was a teenager
I don't know I know that you used you
were brought up deeply religious whether
I don't know if that echoed as an adult
or not but
does that sound right or am I missing
something
I would use an example a few years ago I
was in the Middle East with a country
leader and he offered up his country's
20 30 plans
and this was in 2017 I believe and I
said
that's fascinating that you would be
planning 13 years in advance at the time
I was deeply involved in my Venture
investing in synthetic biology and
nanotech computational Therapeutics so I
knew From The Trenches what was going on
in those worlds from machine learning
and AI through the biology and
and I said how do you think you can
possibly plan that far in advance and he
said like how would you think about it
just as a playful gesture and I said
okay let's imagine let's play a game we
have two robot robots and the goal is to
get the robot to the furthest standard
on the horizon we can barely see it we
can do one of two things one is we can
take a topographical map of the sand
dunes program the map into the robot and
say go robot to that sand dune now we
know what's going to happen in a few
minutes it's going to be stuck in the
sand because the stands are going to
shift the map is going to change
the other thing we do is we say Okay
robot we're going to give you the tools
to navigate the sand no matter what
happens so as the landscape changes as
we know it will it navigate this way to
these endpoints and so all you have to
do is point in a general direction and
that's really what this entire thing is
with blueprint is I've basically just
said my body is a system with tools to
navigate Terrain
as it moves along so measurement science
protocol now the science is going to get
better the measurement's going to get
better and it just improves again and
again and again but my body is not
subject to the same problems of
self-destructive Behavior where it can't
move forward I've tried to put myself my
body in a position where it can have
compounded gains so as technology
improves
my body improves at the same rate of the
technology and in this case it's slowing
my rate of aging and reversing the Aging
that's happened now there may be chances
where we start talking about enhancement
where we build Technologies in society
but if we start thinking about ourselves
that we really care to go together to
this distant point on the horizon we
want systems that allow us to move
through changing terrain what we don't
want are these maps that assume certain
things and so this is the the zeroth
principle thinking so when you say a god
of data I would say uh to me this is a
philosophy of zeroism
you have to tell people what that means
so the idea is
Talent hits the target that no one else
can
genius hits the target no one can see
Rule Number Eight Is exercise oh that's
a good one yeah that's a lot yeah every
day some days I wake up and I look I
know this entire list and I think but
yeah but I do it every single day no
matter what and again you know this
you've been doing this for a long time
now uh you know strength training not
something you know we're not saying it's
something
you know there's a guy there's a
guideline for building up strength
training it's not just let you jump
straight into this uh relatively extreme
protocol yeah we're also doing a lot of
measurements we're looking at my whole
body measurement of muscle and tendons
and ligaments with MRI and ultrasound so
we're able to quantify your dietary
intake
fitness routines and the effect it has
across the entire body tension age
ligament age
joint capsule age cartilage age muscle
age across the whole body
so I'm pausing here because uh the
expert we found when we found my my
jugular vein stenosis
a primary problem was I had had bad
posture so you might I had my chin out
and like my neck jug like this and so I
became obsessive about my posture during
this process I still obsess daily about
my posture I probably think about it 40
times a day
more but always trying to be in a
perfect posture like a imagine this a
string above my head and pulling me
straight up and so this is one of the PT
exercises he has so elbows straight back
and then moving my my shoulders forward
which uh builds the muscles that I need
to keep my neck in the right posture and
this works crazy it's amazing it's
unbelievable we had a with a skull based
surgery
oh that was such a scary situation we
talked to Two World leading experts that
do the surgery so they go in on the side
of the neck
uh which is really
complicated because you've got so much
happening in your neck with nerves and
muscles and and then they shave down the
bone the styloid process uh to try to
eliminate this
narrow into the jugular vein and this
expert we had was like you know actually
like so we were talking about this but
he's like you could also make
significant progress with this PT
and so we've been working on this now we
saw the study where they've done the
surgery and there's no improvement in
clinical outcomes so it's like what the
hell pretty yeah pretty worrying three
people and 22 who received surgery had
sustained benefit everyone else and our
experts said like of course because it's
a postural problem fundamentally like
you sure you've got Eagle syndrome and
other stuff where people you know you've
got other structural problems but
interestingly we did with our new epic 5
ultrasound machine the the Medical Group
hospital grade machine we looked at my
jugular veins last week and it's night
and day difference before you you could
barely see flow in some postural
positions like when I was laying down
but now I want to get it
yeah it was amazing to see the flow uh
how exciting rule number nine is take
advice properly is there advice you can
give
to uh young people today that look at
your story that's successful in many
dimensions
advice you can give to them about how to
be successful in their career successful
in life
and whatever path they choose
yes I would say listen to advice
and see it for what it is a mirror
of that person
and then map and know that your future
is going to be in a zeroth principle
land
and so the what you're hearing today is
a representation of what may have been
the right principles to build upon
previously but they're likely
depreciating very fast and so I am a
strong proponent that
people ask for advice but they don't
take advice
so how do you take advice properly
it's in the careful examination of the
advice it's it's actually you the person
makes a statement about a given thing
somebody should follow
the value is not doing that the value is
understanding the Assumption stack they
built the Assumption and knowledge stack
they built around that that body of
knowledge that's the value it's not
doing what they say and Rule Number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is build a healthy lifestyle
a few years ago I I started going to bed
early like 8 30 p.m and my friends are
oftentimes make fun of me like you know
I remember being at a dinner with you at
your home and we had to end pretty early
because uh just because of that yeah
yeah and I I started thinking through
like how could I make this socially
acceptable and I started to explain like
I I take my job as an entrepreneur
seriously I want to be in great
condition I want to be emotionally
stable I want to be able to make good
decisions I don't want to treat other
people uh and you know I don't want to
be irritable with other people like I
want to be in a positive emotional and
physical state and so I take my
lifestyle very seriously all almost like
a professional athlete and so as I
started working more on blueprint and my
protocol starting getting a bit more
robust I started playing with this
concept let me show you uh this screen
here this image
yeah I started playing around with this
idea of
if there was such a thing as being a
professional Rejuvenation athlete what
would it look like like we know what a
professional basketball players training
regimen looks like and you know we know
this General profile but when you think
about people who are uh looking at uh
their life is a is a office worker or
something else we don't really think
about our lives in terms of us being
athletes or professional athletes and so
if we try to say that we're maintaining
some kind of protocol then people around
us typically bucket at like oh that's a
healthy person or that's a blank person
there's not really a good category and
it creates this social friction and so
I've been playing with this idea of if
like we were to say we are at a point in
time with the science of Rejuvenation
that one could take it seriously and
there could actually be a path for
Rejuvenation Olympics what would a
person's daily protocol look like and so
this is just a sampling of
you can see through images all the stuff
we do but we're looking at every organ
in the body we use evidence only back
protocols so we don't do a trendy thing
it's I gotta be by gold standard
scientific evidence and it's got to be
um through clinical guidelines
sustainability on earth and the
emergence of AI they're big problems
that
very few people can do meaningful things
about right there you can recycle your
Amazon boxes and
you know like I don't know like they're
very hard thing to do and so that's why
uh starting with self is the baby step
that everybody can take
where it's a little bit of control of
identifying that everybody has a role to
play in this and that even though it
seems
uh non-intuitive that you would fix
something within yourself to address an
outside problem that's the baby step and
so to me it's really it's about
it's adopting a new way of being
to acknowledge that um
letting our minds do whatever they want
whenever they want is not good for
ourselves
it's not good for the planet and it's
not good for our future
and that
a new way of being for example of
empowering
all the organs of your body and trying
to achieve goal alignment within self
is a new way of being and so if you map
this out like it here's where I think
we're going if you map this out in the
near future
the
I think what the world looks like is a
giant computational model of goal
alignment
with trillions of computations happening
every second
within self
between each other
with the planet and with AI trillions of
Agents of intelligence and it's one big
tapestry of intelligence
goal lining all the time so in the same
way that my body my body is doing this
right now as we speak like there's
breakages in my in my biology there's
repair happening there's antioxidants
and the other there's inflammation and
there's all these different things
happening and my body's trying to steady
itself it's doing its own goal alignment
algorithm and I'm trying to help it so
it can align itself to its optimal State
and you and I in this conversation are
doing this dance of trying to go a line
on we're talking about certain ideas and
the same thing applies with our machines
and with Earth and so it's this
new way of understanding ourselves that
it's not our minds every whim which we
should be paying attention to
and these are the things that are
causing so many of the problems in the
world all of our heated debates and the
acrimony and the tribalism it's allowing
our knee-jerk reactions to rule
everything it's how we opened up this
conversation you drop a topic in
everybody breaks out into their tribes
they put their war paint on and they
start hammering away at each other and
it's just like no one's winning in that
situation everyone's you know dug in so
it's to me it's it's a new belief system
on how we build ourselves
how we are immersed within the tapestry
of everything else all intelligent
agents
and so again it's it's a little bit of
an indirect answer and it's uh this is
these are Big ideas that are hard to
understand but I think that's the kind
of jump that is relevant for us to
consider
as what is the future of Being Human
because right now it's it's a little
um
I'm not sure our current approach to
trying to tackle these problems
uh is equal to what we need to bring to
the table in order to solve them in a in
a wise way
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Elon Musk check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there when you put your
Blood Sweat and Tears into creating
something
you're building something it's like a
child
um
and so it's like which one am I going to
let one stop to death